45 minutes pour sauver 3 vies le don du
sang est vital pour les malades
une collecte avait lieu hier lundi 14
décembre à la maison de quartier auguste
renoir à guyancourt
en ce moment nous n'avons pas trop le
choix de la typologie des collectes
puisqu'on ne peut pas aller dans les
universités on ne peut plus aller
pratiquement dès les entreprises n'y a
pas assez de monde donc nous organisons
ce qu'on appelle des collectes de
communes et nous donnons la possibilité
aux personnes qui habitent dans le
voisinage de venir directement sur le
lieu de la collecte avec la crise
sanitaire les collectes de sang ont été
désorganisée et les donneurs ont été
moins nombreux le but de ces collectes
et donc de recueillir un maximum de dons
avant les fêtes on s'inquiète pour les
semaines qui vont arriver puisque
justement on va alléger le confinement
va pouvoir sortir un peu plus changer de
région donc il ya les vacances ya les
fêtes mais il faut penser aux malades et
il faut venir donner son sang
d'habitude je donne à mon travail mais
là quand on fait télétravail va du coup
je donne dans ma vie quoi en fait dans
les sols ont mis à disposition c'est
important d'aider les gens puis si ça
peut rendre service c'est tout bénéfique
et pour ceux qui auraient peur de venir
le port du masque est obligatoire
les distanciation sociales sont
respectés et du gel hydro alcoolique est
à disposition à toutes les étapes
comme nous avons des rendez vous nous
gérons les flux c'est très important il
n'y a pas de dan lüthi nation de
donneurs grâce au rendez vous aux gestes
barrières et bien sûr si ronald covil en
ce moment on ne se présente pas sur la
collecte
il faudra attendre 28 jours après la
guérison pour venir donner son sang
d'autres collectes auront lieu ces
prochains jours dans de nombreuses
villes de saint quentin en yvelines
comme à elancourt jeudi 17 décembre à
montigny le bretonneux vendredi 18
décembre ou encore villepreux dimanche
20 décembre